you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution
it seems to me
that
the brain as the brain is growing it is
also somehow communicating with the
skull case
and telling it when it can stop growing
because
you know we have
here you can
literally just bind a baby's head and it
will grow long instead of
round
which must mean that the bone is being
instructed by pressure from the brain or
by the internal organ the bone actually
is probably being instructed
instructed by the pressure from the
binding itself it's hypothesized that
human skulls ossify together
later
than other primates because our brains
tend to grow
larger proportionally to our skulls
so basically how our skulls fuse is that
when you're born skulls are made of all
these little plates and you probably see
it in your casts you have
all these sutures right all the little
zigzags where the bones eventually met
but
those zigzags exist because those bones
initially didn't meet they actually had
soft tissue soft tissue in between and
that's why you know babies have those
soft spots at the top of their heads uh
that people tell you not to press but
it's like really tempting anyway um
don't do it
but uh
we have several fontanelles we have one
at the top we have one at the back the
one that everyone knows is the one at
the top but we actually have them at
several spots including the temples
you hear that folks don't poke babies
heads okay
don't do it but if you want you can poke
the subscribe button and the like button
and the little bell thingy
because you're putting pressure on the
frontal bones
here and here it can push out and kind
of deform those soft areas because
you're not working with plates that are
attached to each other you're working
with floating plates and then if that's
if that continues to stay bound which i
assume that culture you know left them
bound for a long time yeah i think it's
two years yeah or maybe maybe even
longer yeah
i i would assume probably longer but at
that point the bonus has no option but
to ossify into the shape that it is kind
of kept in
uh and the brain just kind of
adapts to filling that space
this skull right here
this is from a peruvian her head was
bound when she was a baby
the really fascinating thing about her
is that her skull is not abnormally
large it looks abnormally large but if
you actually measure it my my nephew and
i did a video where we measured this
using archimedes principle and we
compared it to a normal human skull and
we found that hers is actually slightly
smaller than the the other skull that we
had but completely within normal human
brain size range
she was just a small person
but yeah for those watching if you
haven't seen these series science versus
the aliens of peru i highly recommend it
it's pretty fun we looked at all the
different internet claims that people
have saying that these things are aliens
and then we compare them to the actual
data
well that's it for this clip but don't
worry i post clips regularly and every
thursday i post completely fresh content
make sure you're subscribed liking and
commenting is also welcome